hello I'm had the kits and I'm a global
changemaker hair at the World Economic
Forum on the Middle East I think that I
think food concepts of role models are
incredibly important as it keep is it
cultivates imagination and as Einstein
said imagination is more important
knowledge and it inspires us to look
beyond our own circle and aspire to be
more and role models kind of put the pin
in the map they show us that it is
possible however creating role models is
a very difficult thing there is no earth
there's no there's no one you can let
you can't make sure that the role models
that you create people will pay
attention to like in inspiring you if
you have young people will choose
whoever they want as well and this is
quite dangerous in the sense that they
can be an ineffective role model in the
United States in the UK for example
Eminem a rapper is a very you know
influential role model however he talks
about hitting his wife and you know
shooting people is this the kind of role
model we want to create and therefore
what the question I'd like to pose to
you is how can we ensure that positive
role models have the positive influence
that we need